déficit c'est tout ce que je sais
déficit record pour la compagnie air
france est plus sérieuse c'est officiel
depuis hier la compagnie a perdu 3,2
milliards de francs l'an dernier
alors en période de turbulence tout le
monde trinque y compris les futurs
pilotes
en 1988 il n'y en avait pas assez air
france décide alors d'avoir sa propre
formation
aujourd'hui c'est la crise il y en a
trop 200 élèves se retrouvent sur le
carreau reportage d'eric monnier et
michel levasseur
pour rémi bonnivard volet c'est le rêve
de toute une enfance une passion qui
aurait dû tout naturellement le conduire
dans le cockpit des airbus 320 ou d'un
boeing 737
car rémy était un privilégié l'un des
élèves pilotes
recruté par air france dans le cadre
d'un très ambitieux programme de
formation en 1988 face à la pénurie de
pilotes
la compagnie française décide de lancer
sa propre école aux candidats elle
promet monts et merveilles va jusqu à
débaucher les élèves admis à l'école
nationale de l'aviation civile filières
traditionnelles
seulement voilà depuis deux ans le
transport aérien est malade
air france perd 3 milliards de francs
pour économiser 100 millions par an
la compagnie art est purement et
simplement son programme de formation
nous sommes deux sens dans ce cas là et
dans des situations pas très facile
puisque moi par exemple je suis marié
j'ai deux enfants un prêt immobilier à
rembourser et aucun revenu actuellement
sur 450 élèves en formation seuls 140
sont aujourd'hui pilote 110 sont en
contrats à durée déterminée au guichet
au service des bagages d'air france en
attente d'éventuels places disponibles
pour les autres
leur seule exigence finir leur formation
fonds pourrait trouver un travail soit
dans des compagnies troisième niveau
soit dans des compagnies étrangères de
façon à pouvoir continuer dans
l'aviation puisque sam fait c'était
notre passion à cela la seule réponse
d'air france à tendre des journées a
malheureusement
c'est pas une réponse je vous la cornée
malheureusement c'est déjà une situation
qu ont connu leurs anciens aujourd'hui
commandant de bord à la compagnie qui
ont attendu aussi trois quatre ans la
compagnie et qui malgré tout ont su
franchir ces moments difficiles et nous
rejoindre je dirais aujourd'hui le pari
que nous faisons c'est que nous
retrouverons cette situation si pour
tous ces jeunes
le conflit est dans l'impasse certains
de ses élèves pilotes sont tentés par
une action en justice
d'autres plus prudents préfèrent la
négociation air france pour un jour ou
l'autre être à nouveau demandeur
nous fait